le soleil qui pendant des milliards
d'années avait permis la vie sur terre
est devenue une géante rouge une
monstrueuse bull gazeuse qui ne cesse de
gonfler dangereusement dévorant tout sur
son passage
dans le vide interstellaire qui entoure
notre terre masse visible et invisible
de notre galaxie s'entrechoquent
illuminant de lueurs intense la voie
lactée
ayant épuisé tous l'hydrogène le soleil
est privée de carburants va peu à peu
s'éteindre dans ce véritable feu
d'artifice il va devenir encore cent
mille fois plus brillant de géante rouge
il va se transformer peu à peu en n
blanche avant de n'être bientôt plus
qu'un amas galactiques inerte de plus
dans l'immensité de l'univers
cette image de fin du monde n'est
heureusement que pure imagination et
n'est de toute façon pas pour demain
mais la terre souffre ça c'est certain
et si nous n'y prenons pas garde c'est
l'avenir des générations futures que
nous hypothéquons aujourd'hui
tout avait commencé il ya 15 milliards
d'années avec ce big bang il formidable
explosion une fantastique libération
d'énergie donnant naissance à des
milliards de galaxies qui continue
toujours à s'éloigner les unes des
autres à des vitesses vertigineuses un
monde en perpétuelle expansion
un espace mystérieux dont tel un iceberg
nous ne voyons que la partie émergée on
ignore aujourd'hui encore de quoi sont
constitués les 90% restants la partie
invisible la masse manquante de
l'univers parmi ces milliards de
poussière notre galaxie est elle même
formé d'une myriade des toiles entre
lesquels s'intercale de vaste nébuleuse
de gaz et de corps interstellaire comme
cimentée par la gravitation une galaxie
qu'il faut à notre soleil et à sa
cohorte de corps célestes 240 millions
d'années pour en faire le tour à la
vitesse vertigineuse de 250 km par
seconde un soleil n'est il y a quatre
milliards et demi d'années est situé au
centre d'un système constitué de neuf
planètes parmi lesquels notre terre qui
possède elle-même son propre satellite
naturel la lune
un astre de la nuit explorée par des
sondes et par une douzaine d'hommes mais
sur l'origine de laquelle on s'est
toujours bien peu de choses étaient là
morceaux de la terre qui sont les
détacher à la suite d'une gigantesque
collision at elle au contraire été
capturé par l'attraction terrestre ou
s'est-elle peu à peu formé dans son
orbite
là encore mystère
située à 150 millions de km du soleil la
terre elle se serait formé par
accumulation de matières ou sein d'un
nuage de poussière et de gaz une terre
primitive constitué de roches en fusion
soumise aux éclairs au volcanisme et à
une véritable pluie de météorites
elles auraient acquis sa forme sphérique
sous l'action conjuguée de la
gravitation et de la rotation
il y à 500 millions d'années alors que
la terre poursuit sa lente
transformation
la vie s'y installe peu à peu transformé
par des cycles climatiques qui se
succèdent une évolution très lente des
espèces avec il ya 50 millions d'années
environ
l'apparition de l'homme
l'ère quaternaire et la fonte des
glaciers finiront de données à la terre
sa physionomie actuelle
il faudra attendre les années 60 et le
début de l'ère spatiale pour pouvoir
enfin la contempler la photographier
dans sa totalité la terre une planète
désormais sous la haute surveillance de
satellites spécialisés qui le scrutent
nuit et jour dans ses moindres détails
grâce aux données numériques collectés
par ses satellites et à la puissance des
ordinateurs on l'a aujourd'hui modéliser
procréant atmosphère océans et continent
en images de synthèse
troisième planète par sa proximité du
soleil la terre est éclairé par ses
rayons qui met huit minutes pour nous
parvenir
c'est cette lumière filtrée par
l'atmosphère qui rythme sa vie
contrairement à l'univers la terre n'est
pas en expansion c'est à dire que son
volume ne varie pas mais sa morphologie
elle évolué au cours du temps
modelé par les séismes et les éruptions
volcaniques
en fait ces volcans ne sont que les
soupapes de sécurité de cette
gigantesque cocotte-minute qu'est la
terre laissant échapper le temps à autre
le magma en fusion
éjecté par les énormes pression régnant
dans ses entrailles
ces volcans comme le piton de la
fournaise de l'île de la réunion sont
situés le plus souvent sur les lignes de
fracture de l'écorcé terrestre des zones
d'instabilité qui se trouve à la
périphérie de ces immenses plaques qui
se déplace très lentement de l'ordre de
seulement 2 à 3 centimètres par an les
unes par rapport aux autres
si énorme pavé de croûte terrestre ap
les plaques tectoniques d'une centaine
de kilomètres d'épaisseur de véritables
continent qui parfois à s'entre choquent
violemment entraînant tremblement de
terre ici éruptions volcaniques
cette théorie de la tectonique des
plaques permet de réactualiser une autre
plus ancienne celle de la dérive des
continents
une théorie selon laquelle le monde
était à l'origine une masse unique la
pangée qui sous les pressions
successives de l'écorcé terrestre s'est
peu à peu morcelé jusqu'à former les
cinq continents actuelle dans 50
millions d'années si ces mouvements
persiste la méditerranée deviendrait une
mer fermée un nouvel océan s'enfoncerait
en afrique et les deux amériques serait
largement séparées l'une de l'autre
cette véritable ceinture de feu
parfaitement dessinés à l'échelle de la
planète est désormais étroitement
surveillés reste que malgré la
générosité des scientifiques aucune
méthode ne permet de prévoir avec une
probabilité suffisante
l'imminence est le lieu d'une éruption
volcanique ou d'un tremblement de terre
comme ici celui de los angeles en 1994
seule parade trouvée pour tenter
d'atténuer les conséquences des séismes
la réglementation de la construction
dans ces zones à haut risque
il
pour tenter de prévoir ces catastrophes
qui peuvent causer la mort de milliers
de personnes
l'espoir pourrait bien un jour venir du
ciel et de ses satellites qui survole en
permanence notre planète comme ici la
faille de san andrea en californie
grâce à la précision de plus en plus
grande des instruments de mesure
embarqué on pourrait peu à peu constitué
une véritable cartographie de
l'évolution des déformations des sols
des zones à haut risque
c'est ce que fait notamment ici sur les
pentes du vésuve en italie l' agence
spatiale européenne avec son satellite
d'observation de la terre
rs par comparaison entre les données
enregistrées par le satellite sur un
même point à deux dates différentes
on peut mesurer les mouvements de
terrain avec une précision inférieure
aux cm
une fois parvenus à prévoir l'imminence
d'une catastrophe naturelle restera à
convaincre les populations des risques
encourus
une tâche qui peut paraître encore plus
difficile car les 20000 morts de la
pompe et heroes même et l'activité
constante depuis du vésuve ne semble pas
inquiéter les deux millions de
napolitains qui vivent quotidiennement
sous la menace permanente du volcan
depuis les origines l'homme a toujours
été dépendant des richesses enfermé dans
le sous sol de la terre du métal de ces
armes aux pierres de sa maison il lui
aura fallu trouver mille et une astuces
pour parvenir à exploiter ces gisements
caché représentant une réelle valeur au
premier rang de ceux ci bien sûr lors
qu'ils exercent aujourd'hui encore sur
lui une réelle fascination
autre richesse sans laquelle toute forme
de vie serait impossible l'eau un bien
inégalement répartie dont la quasi
totalité est constitué soit de l'eau
salée des océans soit de l'eau douce
prisonnière des glaciers près d'un tiers
des surfaces de la terre privés d'eau
constituent de véritables déserts
des zones désertiques au paradis
luxuriant la composition et la richesse
des formations végétales rencontré à
l'échelle de la planète dépend de deux
facteurs principaux la latitude
c'est à dire la position sur le globe
terrestre entre les pôles et l'équateur
et d'autre part l'altitude
c'est à dire l'étagement en fonction du
relief
sur les 80 milliards d'hommes qui sont
mais sur la terre depuis son origine
5 milliards y vivent aujourd'hui neuf
sur dix habitants dans l'hémisphère nord
une alimentation elle aussi inégalement
réparties puisqu'un individu sur 10 soir
à sur cinq vivent dans le tiers monde
souffrirait de la faim et sur les 800
millions d'enfants nés dans les pays en
voie de développement
plus des deux tiers seront tôt ou tard
frappé de malnutrition
on le voit malgré les trésors
d'imagination déployés par les hommes et
l'aide internationale qui peu à peu ici
ou là s'organise l'autosuffisance
alimentaire à l'échelle mondiale est
loin d'être réalisée
encore ne faut-il pas que ces efforts
soient balayés par ces conflits qui n'en
finissent pas de pourrir la vie de la
planète
c'est tout parfois chèrement payé est au
centre même de la biosphère
la seule partie de notre planète où la
vie est possible
un ensemble d'écosystèmes dans
lesquelles se recycle en permanence bien
sur l'eau mais aussi l'oxygène la zot le
carbone et bien d'autres éléments
indispensables à la vie
enfin peut-être la principale des
richesses la mer dim 11 étendue d'eau
salée milieu originel de la vie qui
représente plus de 70% de la surface du
globe
trop longtemps considérée comme la
poubelle mais aident des déchets du
progrès des hommes la mer ou comme on
l'appelle aujourd'hui l'hydrosphère
océanique est désormais étroitement
surveillés par les scientifiques du
monde entier
on va le voir en effet que ces océans
sont en fait d'énormes machines qui
régule l'évolution de toute vie sur
terre
il aura pratiquement fallu attendre les
années 90 et le satellite topex poseidon
un programme scientifique franco
américain pour mieux comprendre comment
se comportent les mers et les océans
c'est à dire les trois quarts de la
planète grâce à la combinaison de son
radar et d'un système très sophistiqué
de calcul d'orbites topex poséidon est
capable de mesurer à 1 cm voire à
quelques millimètres près seulement le
niveau moyen de la mer
en combinant différentes données on peut
modéliser l'évolution de l'état des mers
le mouvement des courants des vagues et
des marées
c'est à dire décrypter l'océan ont tous
se déroulent plus lentement que dans
l'atmosphère
en multipliant les mesures à la mer
complémentaires de celles effectuées par
le satellite la nasa et le cnes l'agencé
française de l'espace ont ainsi pu
mettre à la disposition des chercheurs
des millions et des millions de données
première révélation le niveau moyen des
mers et des océans s'est élevé de 16 cm
depuis le début du siècle permettant de
penser que la planète se réchauffe
sensiblement
autre enseignement de topex poseidon les
grands courants marins comme le golf
stream dans l'atlantique nord produisent
à petite échelle des tourbillons des
courants de première importance pour le
transport de la chaleur de l'équateur au
pôle et pour l'étude des climats
enfin on a pu le terminer pour la
première fois avec topex que le niveau
moyen de la méditerranée varier de 20 cm
entre l'été et l'hiver les bases au
ayant lieu en mars avril
les hôtes zoo en septembre octobre
ces résultats ordonné en modèles
numériques prenant en compte
simultanément l'évolution de l'océan
celle de l'atmosphère et leur
interaction pourrait nous aider à mieux
prévoir l'évolution à long terme du
climat de la terre la terre une sphère
pour le moins cabossé par la variation
de la pesanteur et de la densité des
matières qui la constituent des océans
soumis à la traction combiné du soleil
de la lune qui génère les marées et aux
vents qui créent les vagues et les
courants de surface
top exposé id on est ici rs des
satellites qui scrutent en permanence
une planète toujours aux trois quarts
inexploré des océans dont le fond est
encore plus accidenté que ce que nous
connaissons de la partie émergée de la
terre avec de gigantesques fausse vont
atteindre les 11 mm dans le pacifique
un fantastique voyage dans les abîmes du
fond des océans
ainsi
en connaissant mieux les océans nous
pourrons peut-être un jour prévoir et
facilement le temps de nos prochaines
vacances
aujourd'hui encore la pluie et le beau
temps de la terre ne peuvent être
connues avec quasi certitude qu'à très
court terme de l'ordre de quelques jours
c'est la météo omniprésente dans les
journaux ou à la télévision
pour prévoir le temps on fait désormais
très largement appel aux satellites
comme meteosat qui transmet toutes les
demi heures au centre des opérations de
darmstadt en allemagne
les images de l'atmosphère qui entoure
la terre
des éléments de base de la prévision
comme le déplacement des nuages
les températures de la surface des mers
l'humidité de la haute troposphère les
indices de précipitation ou l'analyse de
la couche nuageuse
prévisions météo du prochain week-end ou
plus important de l'arrivée des tornades
ou des cyclones
des cyclones très actif comme ici en
floride dont la violence des effets peut
être atténuée par une bonne prévention
des populations menacées
ces données transmises aux ordinateurs
contribuer à la modélisation et à une
meilleure compréhension de tels
événements les observations de meteosat
enrichi par celle faite par ballon sonde
ou au sol par les métérologues
permettent de connaître pratiquement en
temps réel les conditions météo des
points les plus reculés du globe
cela dit on ne sait toujours pas comment
arrêter la pluie de tomber
une foison d'informations météo qui
n'eut des jours ne cessent de circuler
par satellite à destination
d'utilisateurs de plus en plus nombreux
les marins et les aviateurs bien sûr
qu'ils ont en permanence à leur
disposition le temps présent et à venir
à l'échelle de la planète mais aussi les
agents économiques comme les
agriculteurs qui pour leur moisson ou
leurs vendanges font désormais confiance
aux satellites est le temps qu il fait
sur la terre et mais par la puissance
des ordinateurs est devenu spectacle
propulsé aux meilleures heures d'écouté
par les chaînes de télévision des cinq
continents
un véritable show à la dimension du
monde moderne
ces glaciers qui renferme la quasi
totalité des réserves mondiales d'eau
douce de la planète ne cesse de reculer
il ya seulement deux cent mille ans il
recouvrait tout le nord de l'europe et
atteignait la ville française de lyon
une fantastique masses d'eau gelée
équivalent à près de 30 millions de
cubes de glace d'un km de côtes et
témoin du réchauffement de la planète
le pôle sud voit également à la fin de
chaque hiver austral le rayonnements
nocifs des ultraviolets s'infiltrer
dangereusement dans la biosphère un
bombardement rendue possible par
l'amincissement de la couche d'ozone
protectrice pour surveiller ces énormes
étendu le continent glacé et tenter de
comprendre comment évoluent et seul
désir absolu de la planète
aucune vie n'est possible une fois
encore on a fait appel à rs
lancé par ariane rsa a été placée en
orbite polaire de la terre c'est à dire
qu'il survole ces deux pôles à chaque
révolution un tour de terre qu'il
accomplit en moins d'une heure et demie
repassant tous les 35 jours au dessus
d'un même point
en orbite à 800 km de la terre ehret
surveille en permanence son
environnement
et
ici c'est l'étude de la fameuse route
nord à travers les glaces de l'océan
arctique une route vers l'extrême orient
qui ferait gagner plus de 20 jours de
mer équipés d'un radar lui permettant de
voir la terre aussi bien de numico
travers une épaisse couche de nuages rs
transmet ces images à chaque passage au
dessus d'une station de réception sol
qui va enregistrer et interpréter les
données des images d'une grande
précision qui constituent de véritables
cartes des glaces transmises par
satellites aux équipages est remise à
jour en permanence afin de les aider au
mieux à éviter toute collision avec les
icebergs
grâce à rs on peut ainsi suivre les
mouvements de cet énorme couche de glace
qui régularise les courants océaniques
en jouant le double rôle de barrière
naturelle et de thermostat
terre inhospitalière au sol souvent
gelés aux températures pouvant atteindre
les 90 degrés en dessous de zéro monde
insolite aux conditions extrêmes
autorisant la vie avec parcimonie la vie
végétale olic est né au moose la vie
animale à un nombre très limité
d'espèces sélectionnés par les exigences
du milieu comme les manchots les
pingouins ou les ours polaires
un monde jusqu'alors protégé par sa
carapace de glace mais dont le satellite
peut désormais aller explorer le moindre
de ses reliefs
en outre en prélevant des échantillons
de glace
c'est l'histoire d climat de la terre
enregistrés ici depuis la nuit des temps
qui pourrait enfin nous être révélé
observer la terre depuis l'espace pour
mieux en gérer ses richesses
c'est le rôle de spots ici une
magnifique vue de new york et la
presqu'île de manhattan où chacune des
rues et des avenues sont parfaitement
identifiable un satellite capable de
voir des détails de l'ordre de 10 mètres
sur sept autres villes américaines
washington un satellite dont les prises
de vue sont programmés quotidiennement
selon les besoins des utilisateurs ainsi
spot a permis d'enregistrer a désormais
en mémoire plusieurs millions d'image de
toute la planète
des images numérisées et distribué par
spot image une filiale du cnes des
images disponibles sur cd rom et
exploitable directement sur les consoles
d'ordinateur
grâce à sa visée latéral et à sa vision
stéréoscopique spot en orbite polaire à
800 km de la terre permet de réaliser
des modèles numériques de terrain comme
ici celui d'une zone montagneuse d'accès
difficile
là par exemple on peut circuler sur une
route accidentée qui n'existe pas mais
dont le profil a pu être dessiné par
ordinateur grâce aux différentes données
numériques enregistrées et transmises
par le satellite
on peut aussi survolé une région
montagneuse comme celle de kyoto japon
reconstituer en trois dimensions
bien procédé ici sur les hauteurs des
andes à quito la capitale de l'équateur
à des sondages démographique en cédant
des observations du satellite
observer la terre depuis l'espace pour
mieux la gérer
c'est ce que fait en permanence ce
fermier nord américain surveillant
l'évolution des cercles de terrains
cultivés de même pour les problèmes
d'irrigation des cultures de maïs en
ardèche dans le sud de la france
inventer rapide des surfaces cultivées
identification des cultures et
estimations des rendements les
satellites d'observation le type spots
sont les moyens modernes de regarder la
terre ses bases de données numériques
permettent de tracer directement la
carte adaptée aux besoins comme ici à
toulouse dans le sud de la france
topographie réseau routier ou
hydrographique données d'occupation des
sols ou administratives statistiques
géologique et modèle numérique de
terrain
l'observation par satellite ou
télédétection spatiale constitue un
outil d'investigation exceptionnel pour
une meilleure connaissance de notre
planète
catastrophe tellurique climatique ou
biologique
les caprices de la terre et les
phénomènes naturels qui s'y succèdent
devraient être les seuls à décider de
son évolution
ce serait oublier l'attitude trop
longtemps inconsciente des hommes qui
ont depuis toujours voulu sans
précautions sont attribués les richesses
principal agression catastrophique
la déforestation avec encore plus de 200
mille kilomètres carrés de forêt qui
chaque année sont assis détruit des
catastrophes technologiques qui
s'appelle tchernobyl ou amoco cadiz et
d'autres plus sournoise encore car
peut-être plus floues comme l'effet de
serre les plus acides
la pollution des sols la désertification
ou l'amincissement inquiétant de la
couche d'ozone protectrice sans compter
avec la véritable explosion
démographique dont les effets ne cesse
de s'aggraver avec les 6 milliards de
bouches à nourrir en l'an 2000 et les 8
milliard dépassé en 2025
cette fin du monde prédite à chaque fin
de siècle pourrait en fait ne pas venir
d'ailleurs causé par un trouble n'est au
fond de l'univers mais bien être générés
par la folie inconsciente des hommes
l'appétit de l'homme va dévorer la terre
et ne laisser qu'un désert écrivait déjà
au xviiie siècle le philosophe français
jean jacques rousseau
certaines civilisations ont milité hier
pour asservir et dominer la nature car
selon elle la terre n'est belle que
cultiver gérés par l'homme aujourd'hui
heureusement l'heure est à plus de
modestie bien conscient que tout ce que
l'homme a touché ne s'est pas transformé
en or cette prise de conscience
collective d'une terre dont les
ressources naturelles ne sont pas
inépuisables a été confirmée par les
données des satellites qui en se jouant
des frontières ont placé l'ensemble de
la planète sous haute surveillance
si on sait qu'on ne pourra pas redonner
aux générations futures la totalité du
capital des richesses emprunter il est
encore temps d'agir site aventure nous
décidions de laurent sauvegarder la plus
grande partie